Ishaan son, if you had got 576 marks then you should aim for at
least 650 marks from 576. At least
I am saying that you are fine, there is
no need for depression, you have to work out on yourself.
Look, is
n't it depressant,
these are useless words, whatever words they are.  These
days, I hear all these
words too much, but by
making a big deal out of unnecessary things, you get yourself into depression,
stress or anxiety.
Understand my point, the situation is the same for everyone
who is 21.  Lakhs of children are going to sit, do you
think there is a different situation for any one child
? No, it is the same
situation for everyone, everyone has the same 24 hours, everyone has the
same defined time, everyone has the same
NCRT, everyone is standing in the same condition.
Yes, but in that same condition,
how do you act, how do you
react, that will ensure
selection or rejection?